what card you drive here today
i drove an alpha romeo julia it's not
mine it belongs to alfa romeo that's
where you bar for a few months
you just you get to borrow cars yeah
well i'm like a car influencer i do the
car show and all that kind of stuff do
you like this car yeah
540 horse v6 yeah it's powerful fast car
i like alphas yeah the beauty of working
at nbc and seeing him he was you know
when uh i used to do the tonight show
with johnny carson it was always just a
corvette there was always just a
question
a corvette i don't think jay drove the
same car twice in east i remember when
you were weren't you doing your show
next to his show and every time i would
come visit you it was so much fun to see
what car was parked how many cars do you
have i got 201 on the road 168
motorcycles
201 on the road what does that mean
they're all working right you know
stickers and all that
201 and how many motorcycles
168
what is the uh the most valuable car oh
that'd be the f1 mclaren which is worth
maybe 20 mil
oh my gosh what year is that it's a
1994. oh it's used
why is it worth why is it worth 20
million they only built 64. and they
you know i paid 800 000 for it and
people thought it was crazy and then
they just went nuts i mean the one sold
last may for 20. do you trade your cards
do you ever sell no you don't trade your
car what kind of talk is that well to
sell like you don't want to make no i
never saw i never sold them i don't sell
cars i keep them all mclaren the one
where the it opens up the seats are in
the middle ends
the doors open above the yeah yeah yeah
yeah so so so this is a real car
enthusiast yeah
it's amazing because you talk about this
these humble beginnings in boston and
now you have like over 200 cars and do
you walk into that garage and go i love
my garage
but you know the funny thing is i mean
all my life made people like hey you
know you're being screwed on that deal
that added up they tell me how i'm being
screwed and i go wait a minute you're
living at the oakwood apartments okay i
have a house
in beverly hills i'm not being screwed i
know what i'm doing
you know i i never i never
take my money from my main source of
income i use that to get other money you
know that
you get gigs because you're on
america's got talent you said you ought
you never used your tonight i never
touched a dime on my financial money you
only used your stand-up money i just
live on stand-up money because i like
being hungry if i don't work a week i
really do think i'm broke i go oh man i
just what did i make this i didn't make
anything this week all right just give
me the single patty instead of the
double and a small coke no fries do you
still love stand up will you keep doing
it i love stand up i see him at flappers
yeah i love stand up because
you don't need anybody you just you go
there
i remember i used to have a bit where i
had sunglasses and i take out the
sunglasses do the bit and one day i
forgot the sunglasses
so i said i'm not doing that anymore i
don't have to carry sunglasses i like
the idea of just being i can do a show
i can do a show at the drop of a hat i i
i could go like this but now you don't
even have to have this weekend i go to
florida and i just i bring one suit got
off the plane and six masks tell joke
get check and i'm and i'm out of there
wow is there a car that you want that
you haven't been able to get
no not really i i'm always happy with
whatever i have uh like i said be happy
what you have just make sure you have
enough
but is it you know a car enthusiast
there's like a dream was there something
that doesn't exist anymore and you watch
or you're searching for something yeah
i've got a few of those i've yeah i i've
i've always been contented with what i
have see that's the trick i've never
shot for happiness i only shoot for
contentment because once you're
contented
then you realize oh i guess i'm happy
if you're happy every day it's like
drinking champagne every day now you're
an alcoholic and you just cause
if you're just content contented every
day so you're drunk with contentment i'm
drunk with contentment and then i
realize within that contentment i find
happiness i look back and i go oh you
know something i really am happy i got
no bills you know been married 41 years
have a great time yeah i'm fine
[Music]